[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome, everyone.
My name is Immaculata De Vivo.
I am one of the co-directors
for science programming
here at Radcliffe Institute.
And I have to make a
comment about the weather
and why wouldn't I?
It's a spectacular day.
And we have a speaker
from San Diego,
so I'd have to give a
little bit of credit
to our speaker for bringing
us some San Diego weather.
So today's event,
Twins in Space,
is part of the
undiscovered science series
here at Radcliffe.
And "undiscovered,"
we mean, to paraphrase
my other co-director of
Science, Alyssa Goodman,
is when you are on
a path in science
and you are addressing
a particular question
and you think you know
what you're going to find
but you find out something else.
And Dr. Rana today, in
keeping with that theme,
will tell us the amazing
resilience of the human body--
our ability to adapt in
very harsh environments,
which is space.
So with that, I'd like
to introduce Dr. Rana.
Dr. Rana is an associate
professor from UCSD.
Her area of expertise
is in twins genetics.
Prior to NASA study,
she was invited
to serve as the PI of
several twin studies,
investigating relative
contribution of the environment
and genetic influences on
cardiovascular-related traits
and diseases as well
as cognitive aging.
Previous studies
involved investigating
the role of gene
and environment,
especially on the genome.
The NASA twin study was
a natural progression
of her prior work.
And more importantly, Brinda,
as I like to call her,
is a wonderful personal
friend and she actually
took me on this
journey with her to be
part of this NASA project.
My lab generated some of
the data for this project
and for the paper that's
coming up in Science,
and with that, I'd like
to introduce Brinda
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Immaculata,
and I just want
to say it's a great
honor to be here
and to speak at the
Radcliffe Institute.
And I heard I'm competing
with Joe Kennedy, so thank you
for coming here to listen to me.
And thank you for Dr.
De Vivo and Goodman
for inviting me here.
So I had the
incredible opportunity
to work with NASA for
the last five years.
I've learned a lot.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit about the study
and everything--
all of my experiences
with NASA--
as much as I can get in
in 55, 50 minutes or so.
So let me start with a little
event that occurred last March.
So some of you may have
seen the article in CNN
in which the article
implied that Scott
Kelly, our astronaut, went
up to space for a year
and came back mutated.
Now the great thing about
being on the west coast
is, while you sleep,
the entire world
hears the news before you do.
And by the time I woke up,
every journal in the world
had said something about
Scott Kelly being mutated.
So NASA, in its style--
you know, I mean, this
is what I thought of.
Like, oh my gosh.
7% of the genome is mutated.
We're creating rhesus
monkeys up there.
Well NASA was like,
what just happened?
So the staff at
Houston Space Center
called us up immediately.
We had an emergency
phone call with Houston.
Get to the bottom of it.
Well what had happened was,
in January of that year,
last year, the
twin investigators
gave a talk at a
NASA conference--
just a regular grant
investigators' conference--
and of course reporters were
there listening to our talks.
Well the Daily Mail
reporter was there
and they kind of misinterpreted
are all our joint talks.
And not only were we
mutating astronauts
but we were reversing
aging processes.
And it went relatively under
the radar because, you know,
it's the Daily Mail, but for
some reason, a month and a half
later, CNN decides
to read this article
and pick up where they left
off, and that was what happened.
So anyway, with a little help
of other scientific journals,
National Geographic helped us
clear up what had happened.
So now I'm going to
tell you the real story.
OK.
So in March of 2015,
astronaut Scott Kelly
embarked on a one-year mission
onboard the International Space
Shuttle.
And this became the longest
journey, or longest mission,
a US astronaut had
ever taken on in space.
Previous missions
for US astronauts
were a max of six months.
There had been
several astronauts
who'd take three
months and six months.
And together with the
Russian cosmonaut Kornienko,
this mission was known
as the one-year mission.
So the one-year mission
alone gave NASA opportunities
to study how the human body
adapts to long-duration space
travel-- long-duration
meaning a year--
and also to test out some
of the countermeasures
against the physiological
effects of space travels.
Countermeasures is
a term they used.
You know, therapeutic treatments
to counter the issues--
physiological issues.
So NASA's goal is to send
astronauts to Mars in the 2030s
and they want their
astronauts to come back safe.
They like their astronauts.
So they need to figure out--
they know some of the effects
from the last several decades
of space travel.
They know some of the
effects on the body
but what they're afraid of is
stuff that they don't know.
Not everything is known.
So they're starting to conduct
studies on human physiology.
So some of the stressors
of space travel
include microgravity, elevated
CO2 in the International Space
Center, confined spaces,
circadian disruption,
radiation patterns
that are different
there than on Earth,
isolation from family,
dietary limitation.
These are all issues
that together contribute
to physiological issues.
One of the biggest issues
that astronauts face--
well let's remind
you of the two movies
that you probably saw and
you can kind of remember
all the things that
astronauts go through.
So one of the biggest
issues that astronauts face
is this phenomenon
of fluid shifts.
We have, as humans, evolved on
Earth where there is gravity.
So on Earth, our fluids are
being pulled towards the feet.
Our physiology pumps
the fluids-- the blood--
towards the head.
And on Earth, we're fine.
We get blood flowing,
circulating, in our body.
When you go into a microgravity
or a zero-gravity environment,
there is no gravity
pulling the fluids back
to the feet, so
fluid shifts upward
towards the chest and the head.
So what does this feel like?
Well imagine when you're a
kid, if you remember back then,
and you hung upside
down on monkey bars.
And that feeling of
pressure in your head,
that's the feeling that
these astronauts have.
Now imagine that
for a whole year.
So, needless to say, this
causes a lot of issues.
Some of the issues are increased
intracranial pressure--
they get headaches up there--
edema.
So if you look at pictures
of astronauts in space,
you will see that
they look puffy.
Now this is not a photographic
thing that happens in space.
Their faces are actually puffy.
Some people say this
is a good thing.
A lot of women--
older women I've
given this talk to say, oh,
well that's not so bad, is it?
I'm like, well.
OK.
And you'll see our astronaut,
Scott Kelly, on the top
when he's on Earth.
And on the bottom, you can
see he's kind of puffy.
And then do you notice
anything different about Scott
on the bottom panel?
He's wearing glasses.
OK?
So glasses.
They have a lot
of ocular issues.
Now, back in the day, astronauts
for like fighter pilots,
they have perfect eagle
eyes, but now, they're
representative in the normal,
intelligent population.
A lot of them wear glasses.
But even then, when they go
up, they have further issues
with their eyes.
Some of these issues
are caused by--
they get edema in their eye.
They get distension
in the optic nerve
and then they get this pattern
of choroid folds, which
this is a normal
picture of the retina
and these are the folds here.
Now we've talked
to opthamologists.
This is not something
you see on Earth.
This is something that happens
only because of space travel.
So this is a big issue--
big enough that it
too hit the media,
and this was accurately
reported a few years ago.
Vision changes as an
astronaut's big issue with NASA.
So collectively, this fluid
shifts, intracranial pressure,
eye issues, these symptoms are
known as Spaceflight Associated
Neuro-Ocular Syndrome,
or SANS, formerly known
as Visual Impairment
Intracranial Pressure, VIIP.
So they like their
acronyms there.
Another issue is this issue
with orthostatic intolerance.
So, on Earth, we have a
pressure gradient in our body.
When you go up in space, this
pressure gradient changes.
We have little muscles
that are pumping
blood upwards towards
the head, but in space,
they kind of get--
they don't need to do that
because it's already being--
the fluids are
shifting upwards--
and so they get weak.
So when the
astronauts come down,
the body isn't quite ready to
pump blood back up to the head
and the astronauts can pass out.
And that's why you see,
when astronauts land,
whether or not they are
going to have an event,
they are carried out
of the space shuttle
rather than walking out
of the space shuttle.
Now not all astronauts
have this event.
There's a lot of issues.
There's variation in
how astronauts respond
and there's a lot of
issues, environmental
and maybe genetic,
that contribute
to this orthostatic intolerance.
Other issues are
cardiovascular changes.
So, on Earth, if you're
a middle-aged adult,
you may have gone to
screen for atherosclerosis.
You look at this--
you look at this carotid intima
thickening of your artery.
Normal individuals, they
don't have thickening,
and if you are starting to
develop atherosclerosis,
you get the thickening.
Well these
astronauts, as healthy
as they are, when they're
in space, some of them
develop this thickening.
So that's another issue as well.
They also had
musculoskeletal issues--
muscle atrophy,
bone deconditioning.
And this is kind of easy to
predict because, you know,
they're up there
without any gravity.
And I've been told
by physiologists
that, even though they
do exercise up in space,
an hour, a couple
of hours a day,
that still doesn't
make up for what
we do on Earth with
gravity and just
the daily walking
around that helps
keep our muscle and
bone tone going.
And then there are
potential neurocognitive
and behavioral changes that
need to be studied as well.
So let's put this together.
We've got
musculoskeletal issues,
we've got cardiovascular issues,
cognitive issues, eye issues--
sound familiar?
So all the issues that
we face when we age.
So then when people
kind of talked
to me about this
twin paradox, well,
did Scott really
come back younger?
Well one of our twin
investigators, Chris Mason,
he actually did
the calculations.
And yeah, by a few--
what did he say--
8.6 milliseconds younger.
But really, maybe by
timeline, but physiologically,
I don't think so.
So there are standard
changes due to spaceflight.
We know fluid shifts happen.
It doesn't matter who you are.
You go up there, you
get fluid shifts.
This also corresponds
to decrease
in blood volume, blood
cell mass, and changes
in urinary output.
These are all very
standard in all astronauts.
But there are some
issues that astronauts
face that aren't standard.
For example,
orthostatic intolerance.
Like I said, not all astronauts
will pass out when they land.
Ocular issues.
In studies with the three
months and six-month flight
astronauts, some of them develop
the issues but some astronauts
don't.
I think about 60% developed
it in the shorter duration
flights.
And then something you
probably don't hear about a lot
is astronauts also
get space sickness.
Maybe it's akin to getting
carsick or seasick.
I don't think it's talked about
that much but they do get it.
And so what's causing these
differences in response
to spaceflights?
Is it the environment?
Some of the countermeasures
they're doing?
The environment's not the same.
They're going into space
but the pattern of radiation
may be different.
There may be events up there
in the six months or the year
that we don't know about
that are different.
And then their genetics and
then the way the genetics--
the genome, the DNA--
interacts with the environment
to cause this response.
So two of the twin
investigators, Dr. Smith
and Zwart--
they are the directors of the
Nutrition and Biochemistry Lab
at Johnson Space Center--
they came up with this
multi-hit hypothesis
which is kind of the
akin to the multi-hit
hypothesis for cancer.
They talk about that
the optic issues
that the astronauts
face, represented here,
is a combination
of multiple issues.
Their genetic makeup in
the one-carbon pathway
can cause different response
to the oxidative stress.
That combined with
endothelial dysfunction
caused by just the environment
of space travel interacting
to cause variation in
their optical health.
So NASA, they've
been really good
with physiological studies.
And in fact, if anyone
is doing physiology
and wants to do an internship
at Johnson Space Center,
they're a fantastic lab.
It's a great place to learn
physiology and environmental
response to it.
But NASA five years
ago needed to integrate
new fields, such as
omics system, biology,
the metagenome, which
includes their microbiome,
and then also start
studying cognitive issues
and behavioral issues that the
astronauts are going to face.
So to do so, they decided
to incorporate these studies
into the one-year mission
with Scott Kelly going up
for a year.
Perfect chance.
Now Scott Kelly,
he reminded NASA,
he said, hey, you know,
I have a twin brother
and he's an astronaut for
NASA, in case you didn't know,
and maybe this would
be a perfect study
because my brother
Mark, he's retired.
So Mark Kelly was an astronaut.
He had 50 some days up in space.
He retired a little bit earlier
because his wife, Senator
Gifford, had just survived
an assassination attempt.
So he retired to
take care of her.
So Scott and Mark
thought, well, hey, we
can do a study while
he's up in space.
He'll be the space
twin and his brother
will be the ground control twin.
So Scott and Mark joined the
other genetically identical
organisms up in the
International Space Station.
There was rodent studies, fly
studies, weeds, arabidopsis,
that's being
conducted, and now we
had a human genetically
identical organism,
which was great.
So NASA put out a
proposal called an RFA
and they selected 10 proposals.
And I was fortunate to be one
of the PIs that got selected.
And my buddies and I actually
put in a couple of proposals
and both of them got
accepted, so I was involved
in two of those studies.
And I and my team--
couldn't have done it
without the whole team--
groups at UCSD and
University of Texas
and your own,
Immaculata De Vivo,
we all worked together for the
last five years on this study.
And what is this study?
Well this study included PIs
from all over the United States
and one in Germany.
And we didn't really know
what we were going to do.
And by the way, I just
wanted to tell you
that this is a huge study.
Pick a number in your head about
how much this grant was for?
Just-- it was $100,000,
including indirect cost.
And fortunately, I
was on a K award,
so I didn't have
to pay my salary.
So yeah.
So we got this.
It was really exciting
and got a phone call.
I just happened
to be in my office
when the phone call came
from Johnson Space Center.
Really exciting.
But then the letter comes
with this embargo notice.
This embargo notice, you can't
tell anybody, and if you do,
it will be extremely serious.
And I'm like, whoa, what
am I getting myself into?
So NASA called us all to
Johnson Space Center in April.
They said, OK, pick
your co-investigator
and fly over to
Johnson Space Center.
Put us all in a
room, NASA style.
I think they did this
a lot in the '60s.
You all are going to be a team.
You're going to work
together and you're
going to conduct the
first integrated omics
study of a human body in space.
Put your brains together
and collaborate.
So the idea or the hypothesis
is that Scott and Mark,
being almost genetically
identical individuals,
the stressors of space would
manifest itself on the genome.
So the genome being the actual
DNA sequence or the structure,
but really it could change
the regulation of genes.
So changing the
regulation mechanisms,
epigenetic changes,
which then leads
to changes in transcriptomics,
so DNA to RNA.
Which then, the
products of genes,
which are proteins which
we were working on,
antibodies, metabolites,
changes in the metagenome,
the microbiome, and
then ultimately,
changes in physiology
and cognition.
N equals 2.
All right.
A lot of people like to tease
me about this N equals 2 study,
but I always say, really,
it's actually an N
equals one twin pair.
I do different twin
studies, and one
of the twin studies I
work with is actually
with Boston University.
They have 1,200
twins that they've
been longitudinally following.
So this is kind of funny
to do an N equals 2 study.
But anyway, what we're trying
to do-- well, I put this up.
My postdoc mentor
published a paper
about how important n-of-1
trials are in this day and age
of personalized medicine.
So anyway, what
we're trying to do
is we're trying to
just capture events.
We're trying to capture
molecular events that
correspond to physiological
changes in relationship
with space travel,
both good and bad--
negative and positive effects.
And these will provide
clues for further studies.
And at the same time, we have
the Earth control brother,
and just to see how do these
normal middle-aged man,
how do these molecules change
on Earth and the physiology
that we're doing?
We're doing some pretty
amazing physiology on him.
So we got together
and created a scheme
to sample everything
we possibly could--
urine, blood, fecal samples,
cheek swabs on the astronauts,
both on the ground before
they go up in flight
and on the ground and
then with the ground
twin wherever he happens to be.
Now we were all
molecular biologists.
None of us had worked for
NASA-- well most of us
hadn't worked for NASA.
And we'd been designing
our studies based on Earth.
So, oh yeah, we can
do lots for you,
we told NASA, on that
$100,000 with indirect cost.
We can do this, this, and this.
Just give us a
couple vials of blood
at 10 time points in space.
We'll do stuff for you.
Well NASA said, uh, yeah, no.
Number one, remember I talked to
you about reduced blood volume.
There's a lot of issues up
in space collecting blood.
Not only that, we weren't the
only study on Scott Kelly.
There were like 50 other studies
and they wanted their blood.
So they had a limit of how
much blood they can give.
I mean, these poor guys.
- Wow!
- And they're the best
subject ever because they
collect samples for you.
So they had to do
their own samples.
This is Scott collecting
samples for us
up in space in the
International Space Center.
It's not easy.
He makes it look easy.
And then we thought,
well urine's fine.
But no urine.
They don't like the urine
process because, you have
to imagine, you cannot
let liquid go airborne.
I mean, it starts
floating around
and then you get a splash
of pee in your face.
So they have to
pee into a vacuum.
And so for our 24-hour
pooled urine sample,
they've got to do it in the
vacuum, get a little syringe
and collect the samples for us.
It's not easy.
And then we thought
Scott was hard.
Mark.
Mark was on the trail
around the United States
giving talks on gun control.
We never knew where he was.
But at least we knew
where Scott was.
He was up in the
International Space Station.
So we're like, OK, well
we need this flight
plus 10 days samples.
OK, where's Mark now?
So we'd have to like, oh
gosh, he's over in New York.
OK, send the phlebotomist into
New York to get blood from him
because we need it to correspond
to the same time as Scott.
So that was pretty tough, too.
And then we had to all share--
imagine doing a genomic
study, just genomics.
Easily you get, you know,
one vial, 10 CCs of blood,
and you do transcriptomics
or epigenetics.
No, you get, for us,
one CC, one vial,
and you're going to do
transcriptomics, epigenetics,
proteomics,
metabolomics, everything
on that one CC of vial.
So we had to really work
together and develop protocols.
Not only that.
The protocols were--
you've got to get
everything flight certified.
You know, the stuff
you use here on Earth,
you can't just send it up
there because it may not
withstand space travel.
And if you use glass,
it could shatter,
and then you've get shrapnel
all over-- you know,
floating around,
cutting the astronauts.
So everything has to be flight
certified and some of my stuff
didn't get flight certified.
I wanted a filter to filter
out the epithelial cells
from the urine.
Didn't get that done in
time, so we just let that go.
And then I was a
little perturbed
when the Italians sent their
espresso machine up there.
I'm like, they got an
espresso machine up there
but they couldn't put
my filter up there?
But that's the way it goes.
So the other thing
we had to do--
the most important
thing that day--
they put us in a room for
three days to work together.
The most important thing
was the name of the mission.
We needed a mission
name and a patch.
Now this is important to NASA.
I mean, imagine NIH.
You've got to get a
patch for your study.
When an astronaut goes
up on any mission,
they wear a patch on
their flight suit.
That patch represents
whatever they're doing.
And they [INAUDIBLE]
have tons of patches.
Like I said, there's 50 studies
that they're involved in.
So we had to come up
with a name and a patch.
And what happens
with this patch is--
this is Mission Control
at Johnson Space Center--
at the end of the
study, the patch--
they make a plaque
of the patch--
and you'll see, all over
here, there's these little--
these are all mission
patches on the walls.
And they're ceremoniously
hung up on the wall
at the end of a mission.
And they've been doing this
since the Apollo missions.
So we had to come up with
an idea, unfortunately,
and so-- even the latrine--
the mission that introduced the
latrine, the pee system, they
even had a patch.
I mean, everything has a patch.
So we were trying to
come up with names.
Unfortunately, the Gemini
Project had been taken.
So we came up with a few ideas.
And I thought
Skywalker Project would
be fun but copyright issues.
So we finally just
settled on The Twin Study,
which was great.
And we put every molecule
on-- every single one of us
wanted our molecule on, and if
you look really closely, you've
got the DNA methylation, you've
got every little molecule
on here.
And then of course the names
of all the institutions
of the PIs, and I'm very proud
that UCSD, alphabetically,
ended up in the middle.
OK, so we got the patch done.
Then we had to, in
year one, figure out
how to get the
samples to and from.
So to get the samples
up, we decided to use,
you know, Space X. That's
really what they use.
We had different
types of experiments.
We were doing--
some samples needed
to be sent back to Earth fresh.
Some of them, for my
studies, could wait 300 days.
So the Russian Soyuz is
actually incredibly timely,
so we, for some of the
transcriptomics and telomerase
studies, we timed
the blood draws
with the schedule of the Soyuz
and it came back in two days
from the International Station.
It gets to Kazakhstan,
the helicopter
is there, NASA's
helicopter, where it lands.
They go pick up the
sample, they rush it over
to the Johnson Space Center,
and then one of our team
would be there at Johnson Space
Center to process the samples
when it got there.
And that's usually Fran, who is
the first author of the paper.
And for less
stringent protocols,
we just waited until our shuttle
came, landed in the Pacific,
picked up by NASA
in the Pacific,
taken to Johnson Space
Center, and then disseminated
to all the investigators.
So we came up with
this amazing protocol.
And you know, you're
working with space.
Like I said, things go wrong.
And things did go wrong.
We did have a supply
ship that blew up.
But when it did blow up, we
got this really nice letter
from NASA.
I mean, if you
read the letter, it
says, "Speaking as a
fellow researcher--"
I haven't memorized this--
"I can only imagine
how devastated
you must be feeling right now
on the loss of Space X's CRS 7."
And it goes on to tell
how saddened we all are.
And then it says, "I'm writing
to encourage you-- in fact,
urge you-- to continue
your inquiry."
Can you imagine the NIH
sending you a letter like that
if your experiment blows up?
So we persevered.
I mean, we just lost samples.
They lost food.
That really sucked for them.
And we got samples.
We got lots of samples.
And this is just a
diagram of the samples
that we collected at the
different time points.
I love the way
they write things.
L minus 173, so Launch minus 173
days, or flight day and return.
So we collected from the
Earth twin mark and space twin
at these different time points.
And we did physiological
measures along
with the collections.
Physiology also is complicated.
Well, one thing is, one of the
PIs, Rubin Gore and Basner,
were doing cognitive studies.
Now they're standard
cognitive studies.
You know, they are done
for neurocognitive testing
all the time.
But you've got to
remember, these are highly
functioning adults, so they
had to develop a cognitive test
for the astronaut
special for them and one
that they could administer
through Mission Control.
So yeah.
So remember that the
true cognitive test is
what they experience every day.
You know, this is what it
looks like on the Soyuz.
All these buttons they have
to press to get around.
And they're in
Russian, so these tests
have to represent
their abilities.
So that was one
of the phenotyping
measures that was being done.
Our studies were looking
at omics in conjunction
with these physiological
changes, cardiovascular,
and fluid shifts,
the optic issues.
So we had to do all
the phenotyping.
And this is just
a slide describing
a day in the life of
a fluid shift subject.
And it's a lot of
words, but really
what I'm trying to get at
is, these are all the testing
that we did on the astronauts,
from ultrasounds to MRIs
to dilution measures,
pre-flight, in-flight,
and post-flight
on both brothers.
Really, really good physiology.
And then in-flight, that's the
great thing about in-flight
is your subjects are doing
the studies on themselves.
Best subjects ever.
So, like I said, we looked at
the carotid intima thickening.
So the way we do it,
the cardiovascular lab
at Johnson Space Center has
devised a really nice system.
They've got a computer.
They've coded it for the
astronauts, color and letters,
and the astronauts can
do their own ultrasound.
And this is Scott doing
his ultrasound for us
on the International
Space Center.
And at Johnson Space
Center Mission Control,
there's a little booth somewhere
and then they just call out
and they say, OK, a
little bit to the left,
a little bit to the right.
OK, you got it.
OK, click it.
Click pink A. You know,
capture the image.
And then I noticed on
the wall in the cubicle,
they had all these
little squishy balls.
I was like, what's with all
these little stress balls?
They said, well, there's
a five-second delay
between Mission Control
and the Space Station,
and every time they get the
best image and they said,
OK, the astronaut moves the
probe and they lose the image.
And that causes a
lot of frustration
and so they throw
balls against the wall.
But they're really good.
This is my image.
I got to do this on myself,
with them talking me through it,
except without the
five-second delay.
So I was really proud that
I did my own ultrasound.
IRBs.
They had never-- NASA
had not been involved
in genomic studies before.
And the biggest concern
is here with privacy
and confidentiality.
The entire world knows
Scott and Mark Kelly.
Everything we publish, we're
going to know it's them.
Now they're federal
employees, retired.
They got the best
retirement plan.
My dad was a federal
employee and I
know what a great
retirement plan they have,
so they don't have to worry
about health insurance
and stuff.
But we're talking
about genetics and we
don't know what's going
to happen downstream
with their children,
their grandchildren,
so we have to be very careful
what we say about their data.
Everything has to be
approved through them
and that's how we wrote this
Institutional Board Review.
So some of the issues,
some of the risks--
I mean, the main risk is, you
know, shooting someone off
into space.
But at a conference, the
International Space Station RMD
event, they got Scott
and Kelly together
to talk about our study
and I recorded it.
It's a little bit hard to
listen to in a big room,
so I'm just going to
give you the highlights.
So this is Scott and Mark Kelly.
The way I remember
Scott and Mark is Mark
has a mustache, so M for
Mark, Scott for space.
But sometimes Mark shaves
his mustache and changes
everything, but
this is Mark here.
So Mark jokingly said
that, "There was really
no risk for me.
I'm just shipping blood,
urine, and other stuff
to my former employer,"
he says sarcastically.
And then his brother starts
talking about cognitive tests,
and he said he
was more concerned
about the embarrassment
of doing worse
on the cognitive
study of his brother.
They're very competitive
with each other,
like many brothers are.
And yeah, and he agreed.
So Mark agreed.
He said, "That was
a lot of pressure,
but I didn't practice."
He said he didn't cheat.
He said he did it straight
up and he thought he did OK.
And then he proudly says
that, "In the debrief,
they said I did
better than he did.
So I'm happy about that."
So there's some
data right there.
And then of course
in TIME Magazine,
you know, Mark was
kind of complaining
about sending urine,
pee, and poop over
to us and the
embarrassment factor,
but they're ready to do it
for the benefit of humanity.
So these are some of
the issues with the IRB.
And then the IRB.
Of course we've got to
approve through NASA
and we had to get approved
from my university as well.
My university was like-- they
were like, you know what?
In this project, you're
shooting someone into space.
This presents more than
minimal risk to human subjects.
But they just washed their
hands to it and they said,
this committee defers to NASA.
So now I'm going to talk
to you about our study.
So we are publishing our study.
I was supposed to come--
the reason I decided
to come in February was it was
supposed to be published a week
or two ago.
I'm not going to point
any fingers, but--
[LAUGHTER]
I was at the NASA
meeting last week
and it was very sparse because
the federal employees couldn't
be there, including--
and so I cut out
the name, the director of
the human research project.
They were allowed to come but as
citizens of the United States.
And they had to put
this in their badge
they couldn't talk
about any NASA stuff.
So anyway, it didn't
get published,
but today, we signed
off on everything,
so it should be coming out soon.
This is just to show you
the integrative studies--
all the different
protocols we did,
physiology and molecular, all
the different time points.
And in subsequent slides, you're
going to see green for Earth,
blue for the space twin.
I'm going to show
you some of the data.
And this is really data
that the astronauts
had approved for us to say.
I can't say
everything, but you'll
get an idea of what we've done.
So again, we were looking
at-- in my particular studies,
we were looking
at the correlation
between molecular
events, omics events,
and physiological issues.
And in particular, we were
looking at metabolites
and peptides and proteins.
So we did an integrative
study looking
at, if this means
anything to some of you,
mass spec based metabolomics,
targeted and untargeted,
and proteomics.
And then we also
had some hypotheses
that we were studying about
mitochondrial dysfunction
in space, along with our
collaborator, Immaculata De
Vivo, which was done here.
We looked at mitochondrial
DNA copy number as well.
And then I'll show
you some data.
So basically what
we found was we
found that there were
changes with spaceflight
in some of these molecules.
Some patterns we saw were,
in plasma, blood, or urine,
some of these proteins
or metabolites
were elevated
during spaceflight.
In some cases, they were
decreased when you compare it
to pre-flight baseline levels.
In most cases, they came
back to normal levels.
And then we looked
at the brother.
Now what was interesting
is, in most cases,
the brother didn't fluctuate
too much but they did fluctuate.
And in some cases, it could
fluctuate a little bit more
than the flight astronaut.
And you can imagine
that an astronaut,
when they're actually
on a mission,
they're in a very
controlled environment
versus a middle-aged man on
Earth over a two-year period.
You know, their diet.
Maybe they ate a hamburger
one day, exercised one day,
had a Margarita the next.
So they fluctuate quite a bit.
But overall, the outcome was
a comprehensive and integrated
view of how the
human body responds
to spaceflight and of a
middle-aged man on Earth, which
is very important,
over a two-year period.
So we found changes
in urine metabolites
that related to the adaptations
in multiple physiological
symptoms, including fluid
regulation, vascular
remodeling, and
musculoskeletal deconditioning.
And I'm going to go through
some of the more fun ones
that Scott and Mark approved
for us to talk about
before the paper comes out.
Let's talk about hydration.
So hydration.
Very important up in space.
We observed a particular
protein called aquaporin 2 that
was elevated in spaceflight.
So what is aquaporin 2?
Well aquaporin 2
is a protein that's
found in the kidney
collecting duct cell.
It's usually inside
the cell, but when
the body is
dehydrated, the hormone
signals a receptor on
the cell and says, OK,
aquaporin 2, go out to the
membrane and bring in water.
Instead of eliminating
water in the urine,
bring that water into the cell.
We're dehydrated.
So that's what aquaporin 2 does.
Now in some clinical
studies where
they've elevated
serum sodium levels,
they have found a
jump in aquaporin 2.
And these are clinical
studies that have been done.
This is not a normal situation.
But we found a high level of
aquaporin 2 in the astronauts.
And then we looked at the serum
sodium levels of the astronaut.
It does jump in spaceflight,
as does osmolality,
so they are very
dehydrated up there.
And it's not surprising
because, as you've heard,
they have to
recycle their water.
They're basically recycling
their urine and their sweat
and that's what they drink.
And then they have to use
this crazy system to pee
and they don't like
going in there,
so then they don't
drink enough water,
so the whole thing, I'm told,
is a setup for dehydration.
Energy intake.
Well Scott Smith, one
of the 10 investigators,
he's the director
of the Nutrition Lab
and they've advanced
space food quite a bit.
They have lots of choices.
They're continuing to do studies
to make sure the astronauts are
getting the right nutrients.
They can design their own food.
So it's not as bad
as one may think,
but I'm sure it's not as
good as eating down on Earth.
So the energy intake
does decrease.
And this is a graph.
If you see the blue
line, the blue line
represents a decrease in
Scott Kelly's body mass
compared to pre-flight.
And you can see he
drops a little bit more
than 8% of his body mass
throughout the flight period.
This is the other
one-year mission astronaut
and the purple is historical
data of a group of astronauts
over a period of time.
Green, as you can see, is
brother Mark Kelly, the Earth
twin, and as a typical
middle-aged male on Earth,
over the two-year
period, he gained weight.
So basically, astronauts
are losing weight in space--
body mass--
and it's not surprising because
instead of eating their food,
they're playing with their food.
So we saw some indications of
this in the proteomics study.
For example, we found
a particular protein
called angiotensinogen which
decreased during spaceflight.
Now this decrease
has been, on Earth
in [INAUDIBLE] studies,
has been correlated
with reduction in body weight.
Now this whole system is also
involved in fluid regulation.
So what it's going to do--
the impact, cause, effect.
All this stuff has
to be worked out.
We are seeing this.
And subsequent studies will
work out what it all means.
OK, so when we're
talking about body mass,
I'm going to talk a little
bit about telomeres.
Now telomeres on a DNA
molecule are the very end.
Basically, they're caps.
And they serve as caps to
protect our chromosomes.
They're kind of like
shoelaces, the analogy
is-- the little plastic
tip on your shoelace
that keeps it from being frayed.
Without it, your DNA
starts to degrade.
And telomere length has
been associated with age.
Shorter telomeres
with older age.
So what we saw in this study,
no matter how we looked at it--
Susan Bailey was the lead
for the telomere studies
of this project but Dr. De
Vivo was part of our team
where she helped us validate
some of the studies.
No matter how you looked at
it, Scott Kelly in-flight had
larger telomere length--
whether we looked at the
entire leukocyte population,
whether we isolated
particular cells,
like in this case,
CD4, CD8 cells.
In flight, there
was an elevation
of his telomere length.
And this is a graph of
a population of cells
and the relative telomere
length of the cells.
And you can see that, in flight,
the population of the cells
have higher telomere
length than pre and post.
So basically, telomere length
was increased in flight.
Now studies here on Earth
have found an association
of telomere lengthening
and weight loss
so this may be the reason.
There might be other reasons.
Now the other thing
is telomerase,
and telomerase is
the enzyme that
helps puts these caps on DNA.
In support of the data we
saw with telomere lengthening
in flight, we saw the
regulatory machinery
that kind of regulates genes
responsible-- so epigenetic
machinery regulates genes
and then transfertomics
measures the activity
of the genes.
We saw that that supported an
increase in telomerase activity
in flight and also some of the
genes involved in this process.
So this is how we integrated
a lot of our studies
to show that, OK, we
saw it at one level,
looking at relative
telomere length,
but then we also saw
it at other levels
in the transcriptomics
and epigenetic studies.
So then we can kind
of get to, what
is the mechanism
behind what's going on?
The other thing which I
find very interesting being
in the Department of Psychiatry
is, in November of 2016,
six months after Scott
Kelly returned home,
there was a spike in
the telomerase activity
of both brothers.
And this corresponded to
a very stressful event.
Their father had passed away.
So our study captured this event
at the level of telomerase.
So for what it's
worth, this study
was able to capture events
on Earth as well as on space.
And then let's look at exercise.
Astronauts need to exercise to
maintain their body in space.
One of the pathways
that we looked at
was this lactic acid pathway.
So, going back to
basic biochemistry,
if you start with
pyruvate, you can
go through anaerobic
or aerobic metabolism.
If you go to anaerobic
metabolism to produce energy,
you go to lactic acid.
If you go the other
way, you go through
a mitochondrial pathway.
What we saw was in-flight
increase in lactic acid.
So the question, though,
is what's going on?
Is it simply due to more
exercise up in space?
Is there something
going on where they're
having lactic acid buildup?
Or is it a mitochondrial
dysfunction?
So we did some studies
in mitochondrial function
and that's going
to be in the paper,
but let's look at the
simple stuff first.
Well we were interested
to see, well, what
was going on in this pattern?
This is just the
trajectory of lactic acid
throughout the
course of the study.
So this is in-flight.
It's pretty elevated up here.
Does it have to
do with training?
Well we have to
get data from NASA.
And we just call
this [INAUDIBLE] data
and tells us everything
about the astronauts.
But sometimes the
data is not complete,
and so we kind of experienced
this with the data
for exercise and physiology.
So we did what every
good researcher does.
We went to Costco, we bought the
autobiography of our subject,
we read the book, and he did
say that he was exercising
quite a bit-- six days a
week for at least a couple
of hours a day to prevent
all this bone loss and muscle
atrophy.
So he was exercising a lot.
But there was an
interesting event.
There was a dip here.
We also read the
book and we found out
that he sustained an injury
in his leg during this period
where he cut down
all this exercise.
And that manifested--
and we could detect that
and that decreased lactic acid.
But then, before
landing, he needed
to boost his
exercise so he could
deal with all the issues
with post-flight physiology,
so he started exercising
again and we detected that.
So we did capture
some of the events
of their regular
exercise physiology.
Cardiovascular.
The vascular.
We talked about this CIMT,
Carotid Intima Thickening.
In flight, he did--
so this is pre, post.
This is the CIMT measurements.
Baseline.
And the green is Mark Kelly.
Elevated in flight.
Post-flight, brother's
about the same.
He is still elevated on return.
And this also corresponds to
this carotid artery diameter.
You can see that it's
increased up here in flight.
So we found an increase
in collagen protein
in the urine of
the flight samples.
Now collagen-- and
we hypothesized
that this increase in collagen
has to do with the fact
that collagen is an important
protein in the vasculature.
It's also in the eye--
in the sclera of the eye.
And all this remodeling that
occurs due to space flight,
this could be causing the
shift in collagen synthesis
and elimination.
And that's what we
might be seeing.
It hadn't quite been
reported in other studies,
so this was one of the first
novel findings of this study.
So this is an interesting
marker to look
at for some of these
physiological vascular events.
Microbiome.
This is Fred Turek's study.
The two dominant
bacterial groups,
Firmicutes and Bacteroidetes.
People often study
the ratio F to Bs.
And what they found is that the
ratio increased during flight
and returned back to
normal in the space twin.
In Earth, it was
relatively unchanged.
OK, so and then
the other findings.
There's a lot of findings.
We've got transcriptomic,
methylation data, cytokines,
physiology, all sorts
of blood markers.
They're all integrated in
our Science article, which
should be coming out very soon.
We're supposed to get the cover.
I don't know if
this is the cover
but this is a kind of a
pilot cover that we have.
OK, so in summary, what
does our study show?
We saw both transient
and persistent changes
associated with long-duration
spaceflight at the cell level,
in different cell types,
tissues, and in phenotypes.
And our study-- our
N equals 2 study--
will serve as a roadmap
for future studies aimed
at understanding
potential health risks
of long-duration spaceflight.
NASA is planning on
sending more astronauts up
in these long-duration six
months and one-year missions
and they have had
an RFA and everybody
applied to do these studies.
We don't know whose
proposals they accepted.
That, we'll know in
February, as well.
So hopefully we'll increase
our N and do similar studies.
But there's ongoing studies.
We also do these simulated
spaceflight studies.
And these simulated spaceflight
studies are bedrest studies.
So bedrest studies, you're
eliminating gravity.
And then to kind of
simulate this fluid shift,
the individuals are
tilted headward downward
and they remain in this position
for 30 days, 60 days, 70 days.
They eat like that,
they shower like that,
they do everything like that.
So I'm involved in
several of these studies.
And then they have
studies in which they
have countermeasures, and the
last study I was involved in,
where they elevated CO2 for
30 days in these subjects.
So they were having--
they were at a higher
CO2 level as well.
And then some of the
studies, they do exercise
and you can see the difference
with these countermeasures
or testosterone on their bone
health and muscle health.
So these are the samples
that I'm working on.
And these studies are
a little bit more--
you know, if anybody wants
to collaborate on studies,
I have the samples, and
they're more available
than the twin study samples are.
And of course the
studies like this
has a lot of Earth relevance for
individuals who are at bedrest
for aging issues or injuries.
So in fact, one of
my colleagues has
some of the countermeasures that
he's developed for astronauts
is being used by our
university to help athletes
who have injuries as well.
So there's a lot of
Earth implications
that come out of
these NASA studies.
So I'm just going to
end with, if there
are any students here--
graduate students,
postdocs, undergrads--
who are interested
in working with NASA,
NASA has a great program.
Just go on this intern.nasa.gov.
They're taking applications
for the summer.
I think it's due in April.
And they're a great--
you know, they're a
federal government unit
but they are fantastic.
They are so efficient.
I feel they are.
They might not feel
like that themselves.
But you ask them for
anything, it's there.
It gets done.
I mean, it's amazing.
You always can call
somebody and get an answer,
even during the Furlough.
There was someone there.
And then if you're a
researcher and you're
interested in space
studies, I encourage
you to go to this nspires site.
It's not only the human studies.
There are educational projects
available, educational grants,
and then also all the
physics and astronomy
grants are available here.
So I'm just going
to end with thanking
just my whole group, the two
studies that I'm involved with,
and the overall group
and Scott and Mark Kelly,
and just tell you that
we've had a lot of fun
together-- five years together
working together in Houston.
Who would have thought
Houston could be so fun?
Hanging out, doing stuff.
And in the course
of this project,
two of our investigators
got some top awards.
One of the top awards at
NASA is the Snoopy Award.
The Silver Snoopy Award.
Mike Stenger, who was the PI
of the physiology on my study,
he was given the
Silver Snoopy Award.
And I was like, what?
Is that a real thing?
I totally thought it was a joke.
But then I looked
it up and like,
oh my gosh, that's really cool.
And then Alan Hargens of course
gets one of the big awards
that NASA has to give.
And then just, if you
haven't been to NASA,
I mean, you watch
these movies and they
show NASA to look like
this amazing place.
It is an amazing place but
it doesn't look like this.
It's the federal
government building.
They still have the tiles
from 1950s, '60s, whatever.
It kind of looks like this.
And this is the
cardiovascular lab there.
But that's it, so
thanks for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Brinda.
That was great.
We have a mic in the middle and
please line up behind the mic
and ask questions to Brinda.
- What was the story
about the genetic changes?
Were these epigenetic
methylations or?
- Yeah, that story, that 7%
came from transcriptomics.
There was a change
in flight that just--
yeah, that's what it was.
RNA, so it was gene
expression changes.
Yeah, so there
was a change, they
got that right, they just kind
of put that word "mutated" in
and it scared everybody.
- Hi.
This was the first thing ever
that I listened about space
and twin study and--
OK, forget my story.
The question that I
have is, as a control,
what was the reason
or not the reason
why the Earth control was
not given the same food
as the space control?
- Well that is--
we tried, especially
for the microbiome,
but if you're a retired
federal employee,
do you want to eat space
food for two years?
We couldn't get him to comply.
We tried, like can you at
least just eat space food
for that couple of days
before we do your sampling,
and the answer was no.
- Even if you made the
statement that it's
for science, still no?
OK, fine.
So I feel that it is a bit
less controlled for designs
where you're looking at
microbiome and stuff.
The relation between
the gut bacteria,
which would be highly
influenced by the food
that they are eating.
So maybe I think
there are controls
to normalize with
respect to these aspects,
like the kind of food and
the nutrients that go in.
- Yeah.
And not just in the
microbiome study.
The metabolomic study,
it impacts that, too,
because a lot of
the metabolomics
has to do with what you eat.
And we realized that.
And we can combine this study
with other astronaut studies
and my bedrest studies, which
are actually more controlled.
We know what they ate
in the bedrest studies.
- OK.
Regarding the
bedrest studies, what
do you think about something
which people use on Earth
as a rehabilitation procedure?
They train some people
inside water, right?
So how is it different
from the space
to with gravity, and
I think in water,
the gravity is a
bit reduced, right?
- Yeah.
They do have the buoyancy
studies as well, but buoyancy
studies are--
you know, they're
difficult to do it
for a long period
of time, so that's
why we use the bedrest studies.
But the astronauts actually
do study in the buoyancy labs.
- OK.
Just last question.
OK, just last question.
OK, so the ground
control, was he
like as isolated as
the space control?
- Oh, absolutely not.
He was living his life.
And in fact, I joke about him
being a normal middle-aged man
on Earth.
He is not a normal
middle-aged man on Earth.
He was flying all over
the United States.
- That could completely change
the epigenetics and the way
mRNAs are produced [INAUDIBLE]
- That would.
And that was part of what
we saw, the variation,
but you know, in
general, we didn't
see that much variation
in a lot of the proteins
that I showed you.
It was pretty consistent
throughout the two years.
- Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I am an associate fellow at the
Aerospace Medical Association
and President-elect of
the Aerospace Human Factor
Association.
So I have a couple
of questions for you.
The first is that
I'd like to know
your view on the
personalized countermeasure
because we can't generalize
too much from two twins--
well from a couple of twins.
And then from your work,
can you extract some result
for personalized aging therapies
to rise [INAUDIBLE] population?
- Yeah.
From this study, like
you said, it's N equals 2
and it's just a first study.
I think, in
combination with what
we see here, with some of what
I saw on the bedrest studies--
I did metabolomics also.
I can put some of
that together and I
think that will contribute
more to Earth science
than what I've shown here.
- I was curious whether
you have discovered
from these many studies, whether
there's a minimal time you can
go into space, have these
molecular adjustments,
but come back and
totally rebound?
I'm thinking, you know,
in future decades,
we're going to have
regular people going up
into space for vacations.
So what's the
possibilities there?
Is there a minimal
time that you can
go up and be OK coming back?
- Yeah.
So I think the next group
of studies we're going to do
is going to help address that.
They're sending 17 astronauts
up and doing similar studies.
One-year mission,
six months missions.
And we'll see.
I mean, we saw a lot of
rebounding for the astronauts.
One of the biggest issues
is the ocular issues.
That may not rebound.
And right now, they
have to figure out how
to prevent that from happening.
So eventually, hopefully they'll
find some countermeasures
against it, and then
they can rebound.
And you know, one of the
directors of the program
gave a talk and
they said, it's not
what we know that scares us.
It's what we don't know.
And as they have more
one-year missions,
we'll see what other
effects we're going to see.
This is just one
astronaut what we saw.
Females and males may
respond differently.
There may be issues that are
gender-specific, age-specific.
- Thank you.
- The last question.
- Look at me.
My name is [INAUDIBLE]
and I'm wondering,
you were talking
about the effects
that space has on their
eyes for the astronauts.
From what I understand,
female astronauts,
they have less
effects on their eyes,
so I'm wondering
if that is correct?
If there are any
other changes that
happens to male astronauts
and not females?
And if that also means
that the first trip to Mars
will be an all-female mission?
- Yeah.
You know, I don't think
there is enough data yet
to know for sure.
You know, you did mention
that female astronauts
have more issues with the
orthostatic intolerance right
now.
So we do know there's
gender differences.
Maybe certain physiological
effects are better in males
and worse in females and
vise versa for other ones.
So you know, time will tell.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]